- THIS IS IT?
YOU FOUR THINK
YOU CAN STOP ME?
- DON'T LISTEN TO HIM.
HE'LL USE HIS LIES TO TRY
TO MAKE US TURN ON EACH OTHER.
- THE PREACHER SAID
YOU'RE A PUSSY.
- WHAT?
- WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU?
- LIKE THAT.
THAT'S A GOOD EXAMPLE
OF WHAT WE SHOULDN'T LET HIM DO.
- [laughing]
- OH, LAUGH NOW, ANTICHRIST.
BECAUSE SURPRISE!
WE'VE ASSEMBLED
AN EXORCISM DREAM TEAM!
FATHER QUINN!
- I'M GOING TO NEED TO BE ALONE
WITH THE CHILD.
YOU DON'T HAVE
A NANNY CAM, RIGHT?
- RABBI MALTZMAN!
- NO, NO.
YOU STAY IN THERE, DEMON.
AS LONG AS YOU'RE COMFORTABLE.
I SCHLEPPED ALL THE WAY HERE
FROM BROOKLYN.
BUT DON'T WORRY ABOUT ME.
- AND WITCH DOCTOR KUZNIAK!
- LUCKY FOR US, I WENT
TO MEDICAL SCHOOL IN HAITI.
- AND JORGE,
WHO'S SEEN THE EXORCIST
7 1/2 TIMES
AND LET US USE HIS CAR.
- I'M NOT WITH THEM!
I'M ON YOUR SIDE!
- JORGE, SHUT UP.
- COME ON,
LET ME SELL YOU MY SOUL.
I'LL SIGN WHATEVER CONTRACT
BEN AFFLECK SIGNED.
WHATEVER!
- [sighs]
I WAS UP FOR A CHALLENGE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE
FAR TOO EASY.
- THE POWER OF CHRIST
COMPELS YOU!
THE POWER OF CHRIST
- SHUT UP.
[all exclaim]
SO WHO WANTS TO CHOOSE
HOW I WILL KILL THE REST OF YOU?
- BLOWJOBBED TO DEATH?
- YOU GOT IT.
BY RABID HELL HOUNDS.
AND HERE WE--
[crying]
- I'M GOING TO WRITE KATE UPTON
A NOT-SO-NICE YELP REVIEW.
ETHEL, WHAT THE HELL'S
GOING ON HERE?
- WE'RE DOING AN EXORCISM
ON YOUR CRAZY-ASS DEVIL BABY!
- AND WE ALMOST GOT BLOWJOBS,
UNTIL YOU SHOWED UP!
- CONNIE, WE'VE GOT
TO TRUST THE LORD.
JUST LIKE IT SAY
IN THE BIBLE:
"IF THE EXORCISM
DON'T GO SO BUENO,
THROW THAT GODDAMN BABY
IN A VOLCANO." HA!
- WHAT? NO!
- SORRY, CONNIE,
BUT IT'S THE ONLY WAY
TO STOP THE APOCALYPSE.
- YOU'RE LUCKY
WE GOT A VOLCANO RIGHT HERE.
MOST PEOPLE WITH DEVIL BABIES
GOTTA PAY
FOR A PLANE TICKET TO HAWAII.
- SCREW YOU GUYS!
COME ON, DONNIE.
I'LL PROTECT YOU,
I PROMISE!